I get a feeling there's gonna be a riot
I don't be the news because all right
welcome to another episode of twisted
thank you guys for tuning in thank you
to everybody who tuned in last week and
checked it out I'm trying to get back in
it i'm getting back into my rant stride
I feel like last two have been ok
haven't been great you know there's a
lot of pressure to knock it out of the
park because there's so many podcasts
now like if you don't do excellence
every time I feel like people have
alternatives and it's very weird i know
i just stopped the podcast but this is
weird when a podcast you consider doing
very well just stops ah there's a
podcast called revisionist history that
was going and now it just stopped they
hasn't poet not i think there's just a
lot of work there's a lot of people who
do podcasts and they're like doing all
this editing and all this stuff and
they're like all my edit shows and then
it just like they get like this is too
much work then they stop doing it yep
i'm just like [ __ ] it put this out live
to tape gold hit send yeah there we go
just the golden rules no end bombs and
we're and oh yeah that's it that's
pretty much it that literally is the
only rule no n moms so I don't say
unless you're discussing a woman calling
me in bed or being stuck in traffic now
I'm not even stuck in traffic I think in
an bomb isn't even appropriate in track
you could do every other slur and sexist
remark be really the only time the
n-bomb is at all appropriate is aa in
the bedroom and that's just my my rule
and I must stick with it and if you
don't like me I don't like you and it's
all good we're totally cool tech guys
thanks tune in not a lot of shows this
week I go to China this week big news
as I'm shooting my comedy central ah
pilot presentation with al magical and
Josh Nasar with our host Mike Kosta and
you guys are loved yeah and guess who
they guess who the our Vanna White is
arianny celeste the UFC girl oh yeah so
we go big or we go home so that's why I
got going on sweet I'm be able to do
some up unshrunk but that's that's about
it that's the big bay I'll go to my
YouTube page guys I'm uploading on my
YouTube stuff I just put in an awesome
awesome video i did a commercial I did
for Alan du petit dot-com use
punch-drunk for promo code and I get
some pretty cheap suits we're talking
fifty dollars six hundred dollars suits
use punch drunk and you can go to our
youtube com backslash Sam Tripoli and
see the commercial I did for them it's
really funny its multiple Me's and by
the way I just learned i have somewhat
of a pinhead i have a weird back part of
my head I don't and didn't always have
it but it's now or the woman who cuts my
hair refuses the level off my [ __ ] but
then I never complain because she some
mexican chick what giant tits and I let
her do whatever she wants I'm just such
a sucker for those big Mexican tits so
that's who I am so go check out
youtube.com backslash Sam Tripoli and
I'm put up daily rants daily videos
daily everything just it's it's it's a
video Palooza going on there so sports
is getting some sports real quick
obviously dodgers lose it's
heartbreaking it's sad what role does
Dave Roberts having this I felt like for
the guy who has all the analytics
there's a lot of mismanagement going on
I feel that we go back let at the
beginning this year when we could have
gotten that kid who died in Miami we
could have gave out and would they
probably while yurius I wouldn't but if
you look at the age of yurius you could
the kid who passed away there around the
same age you should have made the trade
we would have that second guy to throw
out yeah it's Yuri's is 19
20 now I think yeah and that kid was
like 24 it's like you'd lost nothing yes
exactly party had Tommy John yes you
likely won't have to have again well not
anymore yeah if you're if you do it
right you'll be all right hold on yuria
said Tommy John no to Fernandez head
well he's dead yeah but if he were here
and still alive ok but he's may not have
needed it again right that that's true
that's true but he throws he you would
have gotten heat from him and he would
have been that second guy and we
probably could sue gotten rich he'll die
got a third guy now you're cooking with
gas you know the analytics man is just
not good it's just I disagree with going
right off faintly you got to go really
on what is happening yeah and you guys
had a ton of injuries to we we set the
record we went we have the most interest
industry injuries by a team that made
playoffs ever in the history of time but
you know when you get in the neck that
the the Chicago Cubs a locomotive it was
just gonna be really hard to beat them
yeah our best bet was gay the third game
in Dodger Stadium when we lost that it
was going to be really hard to win two
other than x3 yeah but you very possibly
could have won Game one well yeah except
for that weird pitch where Dave Roberts
leaves them in again and we just all do
hindsight to the the break of dawn I
just we need hitters we need hitters and
we need another pitcher why do we have a
giant ownership group that has money and
we're not you know because that's what
hedge funds do bro that's what they do
they buy something they lower costs sell
it high that's what hedge fund people do
man another time but they might get rid
of Kershaw they might move in try to get
three players for it's uh that's a big
deal to get rid of that's a big deal
that's mr. Raja right now well that's a
lot of money to get rid of well I mean
there's some people that would do it
Boston if you could get like there's
some markets that would go for him I'd
have to give up a lot they would have to
give up a lot I don't want to give him
why I just want another guy I'm fine
with Greinke not being here because he
fell completely off we knew was about to
happen we need another guy man you got
pay for that man in your hedge fund dude
what's 30 mil a year you make you like
your ass with that well maida maida was
supposed to be that my yeah he's like
lil my it is a great setup guy if you
can go for if you can go four rounds I'm
Iran's innings what is that setup guy
that set up guy no you should he should
be a self guy he's not a starter man and
they start getting to him after four
rounds because they know that crazy
everybody was kung fu fighting
deliveries got enough about us haha ah
mb you know this is the first time in my
life that I haven't been excited about
the NBA star I'm usually biting at the
bit I don't know why I don't know why
but just maybe because the Warriors are
so stacked I'm just kind of over it I
don't think I think they're going to
have games with their just murdering
people I just feel that something's
going to happen inside that locker room
that's going to cause that team to
disintegrate maybe not completely maybe
we'll see a third cavs vs warriors final
it's definitely possible but something's
going to happen there's something going
to go on between dreyman klay Thompson
and Kevin dirt Kevin Durant there's
something going to happen man
something's gonna [ __ ] happen you
thinking devil's threeway yeah I think I
think I think clay and Kevin are gonna
try to spit roast Raymont that's really
uncomfortable to think about yeah but
somewhere out there there's a poor know
where that [ __ ] is going down yeah it's
been written it's been rich people are
talking about it too two brothers going
balls deep on there buddy just
uncomfortable but that's what's guy cuz
draymond our way kicking people high
five and over time yeah just boom boom
boom is that great that's a that's a
that's a [ __ ] term spit roasting and
if you are wonder if men and women who's
funnier who has better name for
positions they do the other people do
girls have any names for any positions
that they do with men no we name them
all and they they hijack our names right
you ever hear girl going oh my god I did
the reverse cowgirl with the give me the
wallet you know what I'm saying I did to
give me the wallet gonna have your baby
fill up by the gold digger you know they
never have any of that stuff
everything's like I made love I made
love I met laughs I love love and then
II bump [ __ ] me in the ass that's it
they take our names they take our names
to take our jokes and that's where we're
at yeah can we get into the NFL what's
he what was that game seven yeah oh man
it was great dude I've never been
rooting so hard for a team I don't give
a [ __ ] about over let the San Diego
Chargers over to the Atlanta Falcons I
cannot tell you I was screaming and
dancing I'm sure screaming and dancing
that's rough I love that dude I'm first
of all just I know Tebow's pissed teeba
because he didn't text me half-ass
[ __ ] like he normally does I didn't
hear from him at all you know he's
pissed you know he's pissed that's a
game they should have won oh yeah that's
a game they should have want and I don't
care what Tebow says I'm going to talk
about on this podcast I love that my AFC
West is the best record out of any any
division we are the best record we have
three guys are basically five into we're
on two charges like 15 though yeah but
the up no no there's the three and four
oh really okay and Kansas City's four
and two cuz I they uh I had a bye week
but we have a mean three of our guys are
only have three of our teams only have
two losses that's pretty [ __ ] great
but let's get down into kickers and how
ridiculous this is that you can't take a
field goal that's your only job man you
gotta you get a locker room you're
basically like a you want a fan
competition and you get to be on the
team and you'll have to do one thing
kick the ball forward and it's like that
those those pile on those toes ahh posts
are like pretty wide and it's not like
he's asking you to do a a 70-yard tick
like
dude you on the 30 Arizona then he
shanked it neither team wanted to win
that game yeah and dude holla bini by
the way was that the was seattle versus
Arizona the greatest worst game ever
like he was so entertaining to see how
bad they were like you're like who's
gonna win this dog [ __ ] game and it's a
tie how's that a rule how are you okay
with a tie that's the most anti-climatic
bunch of bull you got come up with some
you know you need to do you need to do
what what hockey does when over time it
goes down to three guys three guys you
gotta do something man yeah they should
go they should go down to eight on eight
no they should just do three and three
quarterback running back wide receiver
plays defense and offense and they cover
each other and whoever scores [ __ ]
wind to keep like a beach on the side of
the fields oh my god that you put up
those things that it becomes you put up
like bumpers on the side becomes arena
football for one quarter it's not more
exciting would you rather the head than
a 66 tie if eyes could all be like this
[ __ ] A&E this is the most boring that
was the equivalent of the WNBA of NFL
yeah just that was a layup game
everybody's doing layups by the way
congratulations la sparks shot out la
sparks I wanted to go I was out of town
I love it man I'm dude I like female
basketball I mean here's the problem
with women's basketball is that the the
money-making league for women is in
Russia we'll see if that's still going
to happen now now with this world war
three going on is in Russia during the
winter so they all go there make real
money and come back here and basically
play why they have a summer off or they
get paid to not play like down at Diana
Taurasi oh really they pay her not to
play last season I think the Russian fit
yeah they're her team paid her not to
play in the US really yeah that's
amazing that's amazing we see it not and
happens in hockey a lot actually people
pay foreign team will pay them not to
play in the NHL REE a lot of money yeah
really I would love that people paid me
not to do stand-up
dude here's here's 3g don't go up i'm
like done Don I could do that I wish
just keep me on a side coach but let's
get into this guy hey me not to put
these out that what people do that's
they could that be so [ __ ] fine hey
dude I should start charging somebody
says they're watching punch-drunk live
right now I ain't Marie it's not punch
drunk it's twisted I know I'm talking
sports I'm allowed to talk about
whatever I want to Marie god damn it I
lost podcast okay so anyways back to the
kids other kickers this josh brown thing
right sky many journals first of all
what is it with everybody journaling now
like you know Hillary's the emailing hey
I'm doing evil [ __ ] send I beat my wife
journal why are you journaling that now
I'm not he's enough here's my thing
Roger Goodell is an [ __ ] yeah like
dude you had a chance you had a chance
to drop hammer on a white guy and have
no real collateral damage like you know
we have peyton manning before us in a
trainer to lick his taint right and
they're like we can't do anything that's
Papa John guy that was in college yeah
but it did it but where he did happen
yeah oh yeah I'm not denying it you had
a chance to drop hammer and get credit
you get race credit with black people by
dropping a hammer on a white guy again
it's like just like it's like for it's
the foreigner it's the fan participation
contest winner you drop him there's
another bald white guy waiting to kick
the ball yep you should have pounded on
that guy you should not I dude it's
ridiculous that he's on some less he
should be banned from Lee and you should
go over ban them you should go way
beyond anything you should do just to
make a point about how much you love
black people just like Ray Lewis can bet
this guy's never coming back he's banned
for life cuz he's an [ __ ] and we hate
[ __ ] am i right black people you
start high-fiving black life matters
people left and right
just their high five of them there roger
goodell staying up there like the gay
robot he looks like it's Amir's roger
goodell have total gay face he looks
like Donald Trump's younger brother he
looks like he's got dsl's and love some
dick right that's my opinion an opinion
of this podcast is that of Sam tripley's
he looks like a gay dick sucking robot
okay he's standing up there little dick
sucking android about to address people
I black live manner people sandy I'm
like a black chorus right where does yo
mmm mm-hmm they said be hung go mm-hmm
there you go today today we're gonna got
the hammer on that white book lipoid be
paid and then they just drop hammer dude
he's an [ __ ] I'm sorry the guy's an
[ __ ] he should be and you had a
chance to make black people feel good
that there's no racism out there because
like for me man I know I'm not racist so
I don't buy the races and then you see
blatant laces you're like oh it does
exist and I do believe there's race'
obviously cops shooting black people for
no I mean those are real issues I'm not
trying to make light up you know but
sometimes you're like oh man there's did
it everything's about right and then you
see like real racing me I'd be like okay
I'll give you that one I'll give you
that one so that was that um want to get
into speaking of political correctness I
just did a big benefit Aaron I did a
benefit for our comedy for autism which
is a weird name for a benefit sounds
like you're trying to get autism and
they are not there they do not want alt
ism it's a it was an amazing night uh it
was sold out I had a weird week of
comedy dude I had the highest of highs
the lows of loads and the highest of
highs followed by the lowest of lows I
literally was like you know some weird
heart monitor you know like I was all
over the place and so base I do this
benefit was Wednesday night in photan
sold out we sold it out like 300 people
sold out and the comics all killed late
styles the number one burlesque troupe
in Los Angeles crushed I went up out of
the gate cross you know it's good crowd
when the host is crushing even though I
kill at all times well I'll talk about
that not at all times but most times
Greg Santos wound up crushed to Dowson
up anyways as the comics are performing
Andy Dick is on the on the on the lineup
and he is freaking out first of all
there's a kid without there's a grown
man about 50 old man with autism in the
back green room with us Andy Dick's
friend who plays guitar with him brought
him because it was a benefit for autism
but he's like that aggressive autism
like in-your-face autism but he was like
autistic about Beatle songs so like
every two seconds there was like some
guy in your face ask you about Paul
McCartney said no to those pillows are
boss of like I don't know it's like Oh
behind it like yeah and then like two
tanks later he'd ask you the same thing
Oh eat you're grown you know you could
do your if there's anywhere that [ __ ]
flies it's an autism benefit so you're
this guy that's very aggressive autistic
kid is right there and he's uh he's very
much in her face and I I recognize its
can't be easy everybody's being cool
than me everyone's like we understand
and it was cool Eddie dick is freaking
out andy dick is like I'm not a stand-up
comic why am I here I'm like probably
because he got a fat paycheck to be here
which is a very weird thing for me like
the like they paid me to put together a
show and I paid out a lot of money so I
like I don't feel bad about that because
it's like it's hard to ask people a long
time ago I I learned that's hard ask
people to do stuff that they do for a
living for free it's just not fair yeah
but at the same time you don't want to
hos the charity's trying to raise money
for a good cause so you got walk that
fine line so I got a little cash I gave
the comics little cash Jessica Michelle
singleton cancelled I bring in Jackie
Fabolous who's a cold-blooded murderer
yep so Annie dick is just like man I
don't know I'm freaking out I'm like
Andy just do you he's like how much time
do I gotta do I'm like I Teddy he's like
10 I'm like five and then the people who
ran through like he's got two more than
five so I'm thinking they're paying him
a nice check you
I do turn Andy you got to tell kay I'm
fine now what people don't realize is
that neca the college the college
entertainment company made a new rule
which states you have to do your set or
your performance before they pay you
because Andy Dick got paid and never
went up oh so they made a new rule for
so they're like dude you got go up on
stage you got to your tent he's freaking
out I'm like okay plea and I get down I
go okay please we put up this autistic
comic who crushed by the way and going
back to letting the autistic kids get
away with anything he's literally do
like hardcore porn jokes in front this
not Moby honestly fortin they get it
they'll laugh at some dirty [ __ ] at a
benefit which is always my favorite
benefits where we're helping people and
doing well crafted multi-layered dick
jokes but this autistic kid who looks
like Bam Bam from the Flintstones hit
with gamma radiation like 20-30 years
later but all he did was watch porn for
10 years straight like that's the vibe
of this kid he's doing Joe and he's
crushing and he's doing jokes about how
porn is always great because you you you
pretended to you but then he's like I
don't know how to do that with
interracial porn I'm like yeah look at
my big black dick and he did am friend
people went nuts he's like autistic yes
that was a great Joe could he gets done
I introduce Andy Dick Andy Dick please
welcome nothing Andy Dick please welcome
nothing finally I see him walking up
he's in like a frantic mode and he's
like okay I need a so I'm like here's to
I need another store I'm like we only
got one still I just need a chair okay I
need a mic stand we have one mic stand I
give it to him he's like we need another
one I'm like we don't have one he's like
we need another mic stand and he's
freaking out and say so I walk up on
stage I'm the mic stand I hold the
microphone next to the guy playing
guitar and Andy's doing great so Andy
out of nowhere is singing and then he
just drops the [ __ ] right in the
middle of
the the whole he says a word [ __ ]
right in the middle of it and the whole
room just can't go Sonny goes i can say
that i think we all know why and they
start clapping I'm like okay that's a
you know my I have a major problem with
that rule of comedy that somebody could
say something because they are that it
doesn't change and I like Andy Dick a
lot this is an anti Andy Dick thing
because I think he came out trying to do
is best but it's like that rules like on
that person so I could say like like
black comedians rack black the black
community like I'm wasted the KKK wishes
they could say I mean they say the most
racist [ __ ] about black people and
guilty why people like oh my god
congratulations oh that's so funny so he
drops that and people laugh so I'm
standing up it I'm on stage he's like
he's running the light now which is a
classic comedian thing which is like I'm
only gonna do five minutes 20 minutes
later they're still on stage cuz comics
are staged horse he's he's doing it he's
doing it and I don't know where he just
goes these kids are [ __ ] [ __ ] and
dude the room just went nuts I'm like
dude you literally said the one word you
cannot say in this room saying kids are
[ __ ] at art is autism benefit is
like going to NBA also weekend and
dropping n-bombs right in the middle of
singing the anthem before the dunk
contest and right before we do the
sprite dunk contest here's Andy Dick
what's up you pod drops n-bombs right
there it's the same thing dude and I
must say Joan I'm here I'm right in the
middle of this and then he did classic I
could say it because I'm a kid then he
pulls I'm autistic like he's gay
autistic people like half the crowd left
oh it was rough but but comedy for
autism they had nothing to do with them
they put together a great show Islam
fun and I tall ago Annie dick is crazy
it's he's like a tornado of chaos you
you know it's like they're like hey you
want put mop I go I like Andy bites it's
weird juju dude they put them up anyways
and it's fun like comedy for autism
should be prouder they sold out they
wanted they've already asked me back
next year probably after hearing this
they probably will cancel that but you
know it's just like I've been doing
comedy so long dude I've been doing
commecial I know what I can say I know
what I can't say like people like can
you work clean I can lurk Lee I choose
not to because I find it boring yeah I'm
a real [ __ ] dog yeah you know so
brings me into so I do my show at the
improv it's a small crowd I'm gonna be
honest with you I suppose have this one
guy on ain't cancels on me two days
earlier and I was I like I booked it so
we would all promote and when he goes it
put me in a hole and I but I rocked for
like 50 minutes to be proud i got staff
was like that was amazing i'm like i'm a
cold-blooded killer so saturday night i
go to the comedies and here's the
problem i love the improv it's a great
club it's a great clinic again for that
man it's just when you to comedy it you
can't use the rules of road comedy clubs
in Los Angeles you can't do it you can't
sit there and expect the comedians who
go up in town five six seven times to
promote and pack a room on their six
show that week it's just not possible
now you have to aggressively attack you
know who does that better than anybody
The Comedy Store The Comedy Store packs
it because they're in your face always
pushing tickets and if they know it's
gonna be slow to paper the room but
they'll try to sell a ticket that's why
the song you know and the be honest with
you I feel really bad for the two other
clubs in town only because it's just
like every comedy every podcast talks
about the greatness of the comedy store
the improv is
wonderful it's a wonderful comedy club
the staff there is great you have to
figure out how to pack that room and you
can't rely on just the days of just
relying comedians doing it it's an
oversaturation right now only five guys
packed a room Joe Rogan krystalya um Jim
Jeffries who else probably Benson Kevin
Smith yeah but he doesn't do stander
stand up but I mean if you put him on
some but he's not really gonna do it no
but I'm trying to think about who else
is on that list of guys that just ah
Anthony Jeselnik sin there but I mean
like there's not a lot of people I mean
Liza schlessinger people of her I don't
know if she'll pack a room some just
told me there was a Booker they said if
you don't bring a couple hundred people
to every show you do you don't have a
draw I'm like you're [ __ ] [ __ ]
your didn't [ __ ] I mean Rogen can do
it but if he did five gigs in one night
you wouldn't have it packed every night
nobody would I mean like Lucy k does it
but he's just weird dude I don't know
him and obviously bill burr too he's a
nap talk but for them but that's like
six guys everybody else is just my
problems I can't get people worship at
my altar I destroy rooms i'm a world
destroyer which brings me to my gig and
uh brings me to my gig in AA at the
comedy source so saturday and i get call
like am I supposed to mike young spock
guys like me me down there I go there
Mike Young's there he doesn't want he's
he's he's like I can't do it I'm like
okay I'm here early damn locks up
because I dude you want to do five
minutes in the main room I'm like [ __ ]
yeah I walk in it's sold out nice 400
Sebastian's on crushing now I go up and
I'm like okay afford your room crusher
at about the show starts at nine this
shows that it's about ten-thirty you
can't go up there and just do smoking
crack with robot bit he can't do it
they're just not ready for they've been
lolled into this the sense of warmth you
know that's where the mainstream guys go
up girls do this guy's do that i'm
italian baba that's what
they go so I have to scrape my act and I
crush I crushed 409 staff came out to me
you killed dude I can go up any time I'm
versatile I just choose to be honest on
stage yeah and they're like imma be
honest if you think I'm bragging right
on just know at night I cry myself to
sleep I cry myself to sleep wondering
what I've done with my [ __ ] life so
anyways I crush in the main room I go
into the o.r and they asked me so dry
Carmichael goes up he's a [ __ ] killer
I loved rod Carmichael he goes up I saw
and he's smooth jazz man he's smooth
jazz my energies different I have to
learn there's just like like falling
Joey Diaz is different than following
draw Carmichael now there are two
different comics and they have different
comedy level I think jerod Carmichael is
a phenomenal comic I mean obviously Joey
Diaz is probably the hardest person to
plan to cut follow but draw it as his
own hard and that you got to kind of
match his energy and bring it up I
didn't do that I went raiding to this
bit about how this guy I saw in this is
a true story and it's been killing
everywhere how this guy came up to me
the other day with a giant la tattoo on
his face a giant tattoo on his face
asking for directions on how to get
around our lay right that's funny yeah
crowd stared at me just [ __ ] stared
at me and had this great bit i was gonna
go into that about the Dodgers and how
to like the end of the season was VIN
Scully's last game right two weeks later
he's back at the park it took two weeks
for his wife to drive him [ __ ] nuts
after 69 years on the job he's like oh
the phones ringing oh hello Andrew
Friedman hello yeah honey it's and you
fit the phone did ring yeah I did say hi
it's andrew what angel why oh you need
me at the ballpark Oh first char once
again tomorrow I'll leave now honey he
needs me you're lying then there's
nobody on there why are you leaving you
quit that job now they need me honey we
gotta beat the Cubs cuz it's time for
Dodger baseball
good [ __ ] vin scully gonna kill a
[ __ ] no a hedgehog they just stared at
me that's a quality [ __ ] bit yep
that's a quality bit they just stared at
me and I get into this bit about how
everybody's bisexual now everybody's
watch so much porn it's just everyone's
by and I go into this thing you know
it's like there's national coming out
day to see that national coming out day
is when every actress who hot actress in
la who's not working does a big
announcement about how they're bisexual
and they're just so happy to be out of
the closet it's like finally they can be
themselves like oh like Miley Cyrus is
like oh I'm so happy I can finally be
myself Oh Miley tell me about the hard
days of being in the closet would you
have to pay for your own cocaine how was
that like black ditch black dick and
snatch you know you want to shock me you
know it'd be amazing if Peyton Manning
came out of closet he's like you know we
are it was a hard game we played a hard
game and all you know the offense
clicking the defense stop them Aaron you
know I just gotta be like I'm just gonna
go out Papa John's on some latino boy
ass you know I'm talked about stuffed
crust pizza you know I'm job as it worse
pay Manny impression but it was great
you know and i just spent about by and
they just stared at me because I thought
Kevin Elliot let me do this part of his
he had a joke about the T literally
walked in on two dudes [ __ ] at a
Chipotle and I'm like dude you there he
goes now I go can I do he goes [ __ ] yeah
and I tag that they just stared at me
like they were fine we're two dudes
[ __ ] at a Chipotle I know you'll do
that chipotle you do that a Bosch afresh
if you're gonna [ __ ] you [ __ ] Bosh
out fresh nope nobody's with me on that
one killed in the room I think it's
Prince Baha Baha Baha Baha Baha haha
California is a baja fresh yeah that
might be why hmm well you know I'll give
a [ __ ] listen dude everybody hates I
just can't wait to this election so
I just want to get it son I was gonna
going up some not Madonna but I just
want I'm gonna do one more thing and
then we're gonna get the [ __ ] out of
here I just dude I i won't go into
something real quick I believe it or not
I even though I hate Hillary Clinton I
am a liberal and I am a Democrat and
people don't seem to understand that and
they be literally the only thing i don't
like about the Democratic Party is
Hillary Clinton and I get called all
right all the time which I'm the
farthest thing from I'm a weird dude man
I've been a weird [ __ ] I'll I shine in
the darkness I just don't like that Seth
lord man and it doesn't mean I'm a
[ __ ] all right guy I mean like dude
I'm a big animal dude like I won't get
in some Emma and this I am NOT in to
trophy hunting it's not my thing man but
I know that hunting is as primal as it
gets it is as basic natural as anything
out there it's as natural as as giving
birth it's as natural as having to eat
it's just part of life hunting is a part
of life I have no problem with hunting
for food if you want to hunt for food
humph from food you see Joe Rogan does
that he kills an elk he cuts it up he
gives friends Elks me I've no problem
that it says probably you can't be for
nature and then be against hunting it
says primals get it sucks something's
gotta get eaten but that's life I prefer
to be more of a fair fight that's what I
want to get too dude it's just like
these people like no dude first of all
don't you know really helps these people
that really helps those people and
animals need to give gifts in well the
story that that got me was this English
rugby player a shot an elephant they
heard it screaming in pain and guys like
you got thin the herd not the elephants
there's not enough elephants yeah we're
running out of elephants why are you
shooting an elephant and then bragging
about it and there's nothing there's
nothing sporting or tough about shooting
something from a thousand feet away with
a high power
rifle remember look Palin try to make it
legal to hunt from helicopter with a
machine gun like why is that cool listen
dude you wanna hunt I don't get it you
want a game on here's what you do
[ __ ] get a knife and you go [ __ ]
hunt that's tough guy ship you versus
the animal winner takes all this [ __ ]
high power rifle that's chicken [ __ ] yep
it's just chicken [ __ ] if you want to
put something on your wall earn that
[ __ ] like I got the value of life is
hilarious like people think animals are
just here to for our fodder and they're
not where it's an ecosystem we all have
to live off each other and when the
Lauren dies we're all in trouble like
we're killing off bees right now and
nobody cares because they're too busy
worrying about [ __ ] Trump doing
grab-ass to give a [ __ ] there is a
hierarchy in life and it starts with
white women at the top white women are
the most protective thing in the world
we protect them more than anything and
when a white woman gets killed everybody
runs around like it's heads are cut off
there goes white women then goes
minorities then it goes white guys then
it goes the rest of the world like you
know maybe Canadians nobody cares in
this country of Canadian gets killed and
then it goes all the way down the third
world [ __ ] people why is one value of
life more than the other and I know we
can't all sit around and get angry when
any one person dies when there's six
billion of us but the notion that animal
life isn't worth anything is ridiculous
we should all live here together there's
no reason to destroy this planet other
than corporate greed and we should be
[ __ ] hanging dudes from trees these
[ __ ] bankers they should be hanging
from trees hunt them men hunt them dude
Bob somebody's don't try to kidnap these
guys [ __ ] them man I just like it's just
there's no need for it man first of all
there's too many of us okay there's just
too many of we gotta stop we gotta
promote anal and less [ __ ] baby makin
you get to people you
place you and your lady and that's it
that's the end I just don't I just like
man we just don't have to hurt I just
don't get it here's my rule don't steal
don't hurt another living being don't
hurt children those are the rules
anything after that have fun have fun
stick dick in weird places man enjoy it
your girlfriend wants have trains ran on
her while you watch enjoy you want to
[ __ ] a pumpkin enjoy I don't care just
you know there's no reason to bring pain
and suffering to anybody and that's my
opinion man and that's why I go off to I
understand hunting I respect hunting I
respect you know the act it says natural
talent but if you want to be a tough guy
and put some [ __ ] head on your wall
you go get a knife and you [ __ ] hunt
that thing alright so I want to play
this one all thing real quick it's about
four minutes and then we'll get out of
here okay great great i hope you guys
have fun i enjoyed this here we go this
is a motivational thing i like to do
these if you believe you are something
you actually embody it you embody that
feeling if you were God forbid in a coma
and you woke up and you didn't really
have a memory and you were told that you
used to be a Navy Seal and they want you
back now when you're healthy do you
think you'd act differently and hold
yourself differently conduct yourself
different have a different self concept
of who you are then if you told you were
a piano instructor being successful in
life is all about having the proper
belief system and who you are truly
believing that you are something unique
that you are something special in that
field
if you truly believe inside of you that
you are one of the best actors in the
world you will be entirely different
than if you're like I hope I'm good your
expressions will be totally different
your tone of voice you're talking to
more convincing fashion you use your
natural voice instead of a scripted
you'll be more in phatak you'll be more
real more relatable our brain is like a
circuit and so if we introduce it with
the proper wired you're gonna go
straight to your time if you're unsure
about who you are then your dreams your
goals they will never become a reality
everyone has mental doubts in life
internal conflicts even the most
successful people that you look up to
but they don't live there it's how you
handle those negative thoughts in that
exact moment and overwhelm them with
positive action and that comes with this
upmost confidence in yourself that you
can handle the situation trust in
yourself that you are better than the
moment the great thing differently that
the great see differently right that the
greats have a different worldview the
great they approach the game in a
totally different way so I need you to
do me a huge favor I need you to think
about what you're thinking about when
your effort is low because if you can
get this if you can get this you can get
any success you want to life you can
have anything you want in life if you
can get this
the next time you give a low effort
right you give a seventy percent or
fifty percent or thirty percent I want
you to think about what you're thinking
about when your effort is low if your
effort is low you're probably not
thinking about the opportunity you're
probably thinking about the obligation
and when you think about atieast a
[ __ ] up eating's how you stay on fire
et how you always driven even in your
mrs. child in tribulation even though
mr. your haters where people try to
break you and tell you down ET i would
say strong i keep thinking about
this is an opportunity
if you want what you've never had before
if you want to do what you've never done
before if you want to be what you've
never been before change your mentality
and I want you to see that ever goes up
when you when you look at it add I got
an opportunity of a lifetime but you
should be excited about the fact that
you have an opportunity